Next up.
We could have a brand new skyscraper coming to town.
TimeOut reports, the affirmation tower,
an upside down skyscraper designed by architect, David Ajay.
Whoa.
An incredible gentleman
behind the African American history museum in D.C.
Now it could be the second tallest building in New York,
right behind One World Trade.
That's fascinating.
Uh-huh.
More importantly, it would house the NAACP
and a number of minority owned businesses.
That's impressive.
(audience applauding)
I love that.
The building proposal
includes over 30% of construction
going to women and minority contractors.
(crowd cheering)
That too groundbreaking
I mean is the metaphor that like
upside down is right side up.
I mean, they just really wanna get it right
with making this building.
I will say I applaud this building
but I may never go to the top of this building.
Did you see that it, how it's built?
It's literally like an upside down.
Okay. That makes me slightly nervous. Right?
Would you go to the top of it?
It's funny because when I first saw this, I was like whoa
But then hearing why and how the building is coming out.
Yeah.
I'm, it's so meaningful to me.
I wanna get right in it.
Understood. Maybe you convinced me.
I would first.
I was like, maybe I'll be on the first floor, but okay.
Take me to new Heights.
I couldn't agree more.
Okay. Next it's time for Drew's reviews.
(crowd cheering)
And today we've got something super exciting submitted
by viewer Kelly Fleming. Thank you, Kelly.
Hi Kelly. So apparently I just found this out too.
Music legend, an American icon.
Dolly Parton makes a mean scrambled egg.
I love picturing her in the kitchen.
Just whipping, whipping eggs.
It's like, there's nothing she can't do.
Right.
Apparently she says that
she has a trick up her sleeve though.
So she makes them to get them nice and fluffy
she adds a little ice water as she scrambles.
Oh really?
Ahan.
Do you know what else she does?
She cooks them for about nine to five minutes.
(crowd cheering)
Oh, Okay. I'm so excited to try,
Dolly's secret of pouring a little bit
of ice water as you scramble and whip.
Hmm.
I mean the fluff is there.
(crowd laughing)
It tastes like scrambled eggs.
(crowd applauding)
I mean, I want to be like, oh my God, Dolly part
you have reinvented eggs because I love you so much.
But thanks.
Here's one thing that I do wanna point out.
Dolly has given us so much music, fluffy, your eggs.
Yeah.
And it's just been reported literally today
that she's gonna pay
college tuition for all Dollywood employees.
(crowd applauding)
Now that full time, part time, seasonal employees.
And if you wanna further your education
Dolly's got you covered.
And I wanna say
as someone who is a lifelong Dolly Parton fan
and I've been to Dollywood,
Me too.
Dolly Parton you do get infinite stars forever.
Amen.
Thank you for being real.
(upbeat music)